unique est super fort c'est féerique
majestueux ferme bio l'os maison
elles font toujours briller les yeux ces
grandes eaux du château de versailles
depuis plus de 350 ans les 600 jeux
d'eau débute au printemps un ballet
majestueux préparé par les treize
fontenay
[Musique]
c'est toujours la même émotion d'offrir
le travail de l'hiver où tout a été
entretenue réparé pour que l'année 2010
8 commence avec de belles zoé et va
durer toute la saison aux sondés jean
baptiste lui jean philippe rameau et
marc antoine charpentier 55 fontaines et
bassins s'anime
parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin de neptune
le bassin neptune est un bassin qui est
le plus vaste avec son système de
fontaines ancien de tout le château est
un des plus vastes d'europe avec près de
150 mètres entre guillemets de dénivelé
de fond de dérouler de fontaine par
contre comme il consomme énormément
d'eau il ne peut être mise en doute très
rarement
donc on a trouvé un système automatisé
dans le centre du bassin là où il n'y a
pas de fontaine ancienne pour proposer
au public à cet endroit une activité
hydraulique qui ne soit pas celle de la
fontaine ancienne
avec plus de 100 représentations les
grandes zoé jardins musicaux sont une
invitation à la promenade dans les pas
du roi soleil un instant suspendu qui
attire chaque année près de 12000
visiteurs par jour
[Musique]